öa Chief art officer is one of the face
commanders of the two new brothers War
Commander precon decks and you the
community voted on him for me to do a
quick budget upgrade the total price for
all the new cards I've added to this
list is about 25 bucks with the most
expensive card being $4 and the average
card price being just 90 now with that
out of the way first things first what's
the game plan
[Music]
let's quickly go over öa Chief artificer
for three generic a blue a black and a
white we get a four five that has
Infinity for artifact creatures meaning
öa costs one generic Mana less for each
artifact creature we control so if we
have three artifact creatures he would
cost white blue and black something to
note this affinity for artifacts can
also cover command attacks so if we cast
öa from the command zone for a second
time and we have five artifact creatures
he will still only cost a white a blue
and a black next artifact creatures you
control have Menace meaning artifact
creatures can only be blocked by two or
more
creatures and finally at the beginning
of our endep create a0000 colorless
construct artifact creature token with
this creature gets plus one + one for
each artifact we control whereas most
people call them a construct So the plan
is simple play cheap artifact creatures
and Mana rocks to get ö and play ASAP
create an overwhelming robot army of
constructs and thopters and protect the
commander-in-chief öa and without
further Ado let's get into
[Music]
it to start I added the three myrr Manor
rocks in our colors gold myr Leen myrr
and silver myr I also added in their
older brother Paladin myr which Taps for
two colorless Mana continuing with the
myrr family I've also added Shimmer My
which gives all our artifacts flash all
of the myr Bros combine nicely with my
battle sphere 2 our final additional
minor is oropa of paradise it Taps for
any color as well as helping reduce 's
Infinity cost as an added bonus it also
flies which may come in handy later on
in the game when we're attacking with
our creatures this additional minor is
also excellent for pumping into digsite
engineer to get even more
constructs to also help with the ramping
chief engineer gives our artifact spells
convoke meaning we can tap any of our
creatures including thopters and
construct tokens to help cast any of our
artifacts founder inspector and jeor is
familiar also helped reduce the cost of
the majority of our spells now now we've
got our Manor in play it's time to
summon öa and protect
[Music]
him now because ö is such a Powerhouse
in this deck I've added a couple of
different ways we can protect him first
up we have the counter spells we've got
access denied a five Mana hard counter
that generates us a bunch of flying
thopters the bigger the spell The More
thopters We Get I really like this card
as we can counter someone's big spells
and then potentially kill them when the
turn Cycles back to us I've added in
negate a nice cheap Manor efficient
spell that can not only protect öa it
can stop any board wipes trying to
destroy our army and finally for
counters we have stoic rebuttal nine
times out of 10 is just a straight up
counter spell and of course when you
have the budget you can just swap it out
for counter spell in terms of other ways
to protect öa I added Lauren's escape
this is a really nice card as for just
one white Mana we can not only protect
our commander but if we need to we can
turn it towards one of our other
important
artifacts another nice protection
Synergy you should be aware of is the
interaction between liquid metal torque
and new addition Pim Council of
innovation just keep in mind with these
two on the battlefield you can quickly
turn öa into an artifact and give him
hex proof If you need to protect him
from a single Target removal don't
forget to protect S 2 he is about as
important as erser in this deck speaking
of removal I've added in some catch all
removal with fracture utter end and void
Rend these are mainly here to stop cards
that would upset our strategy and remove
opponent's combos I've also swapped out
both board wipes and gone for a single
organic Extinction instead there is one
more board wipe I would like to add but
more on that later oh and as a pseudo
board wipe I've also included perplexing
test as most of our army is going to be
tokens and the fact that we can quickly
stack cost reduction and recast
everything this card is excellent for
clearing the way for a lethal
[Music]
swing because we're in artifact deck
there are plenty of simple combos we can
use to win the game so to make sure we
hit these I've added a tiny bit more
card draw first for knowledge is an
instant speed draw three discard one
most of the time research Thief allows
us to swing in with a couple of innocent
one one thopters and then out of nowhere
turn them into Baby Shadow Mage
infiltrators and draw a bunch of cards
and while it's not card draw ether sworn
Sphinx is generally a two Manor Cascade
that can hit everything in our Deck bar
one card so getting a 44 flyer and a
bonus spell all for Just Two Mana seemed
too good to pass up with drawing all
these cards this lets us power up the
new edition efficient construction for
every artifact spell we cast we get a
bonus flying thopter and with all these
additional artifacts nettle cyst was an
easy inclusion it can be a threat by
itself or you can simply attach it to
one of our flyers and likely swing for a
lethal hit or you can simply awaken
every non-creature artifact and turn
them into 44s with flying thanks to
cyberdrive awakener this six Mana 44 is
an absolute Allstar and if you're only
able to pick up one card to upgrade this
deck this should be it and if you can't
win with cyberdrive awakener you simply
only need to add one more card to the
precon and you unlock yourself an
infinite life loss combo all you need to
add is just a single sculpting steel
here's how the combo goes how a
marionette Master on the battlefield or
the backup I added disciple of the Vault
and have either sculpting Steel in the
graveyard and a shirom the hedgemon in
your hand or a shirom in play and a
sculpting Steel in hand let's just say
we have both in our hand we cast shirom
and bring back an artifact from the
graveyard we then cast sculpting steel
copying shirom before triggers are
placed on the stack the legend rule
takes effect we put either sh room or
sculpting steel into the graveyard and
then when triggers are placed on the
stack we target whichever one went to
the graveyard and thanks to marionette
master or disciple of the Vault an
opponent will lose life you can then
repeat this Loop until you win the
game the final two cards are one of my
favorite combos SL synergies sword of
the meek and thop to Foundry with these
two cards in play we can make as many
thopters and gain as much life as we
have Manor available
with the sword and Foundry in Play We
sacrifice the sword to The Foundry and
make a one- one flying thopter when that
happens the sword comes back from the
graveyard and attaches to that creature
we can then repeat the combo at instant
speed for as much Mana as we have it's
because of this combo and cyber drive
awakener that I've left all the Mana
rocks in The Deck bar one don't forget
there's only one caveat with this combo
if you have the tempered steel in play
the thopter will not be 1 On's and will
not trigger sord of the meek so make
sure to treat tempered steel as a
surprise instead of just slamming it
down on turn
[Music]
three now you'll have noticed that I
didn't include any of the Warhammer 40K
cards and that's because they're so damn
hard to get a hold of right now but
there are three you should keep an eye
out for the two budget ones are crypto
throl and their name is dead death
crypto throw is another way to protect
all our key artifacts while their name
is death is just another one-sided board
wipe and if you can track one down biot
transference makes all the constructs
massive while generating even more
artifacts for some non 40K upgrades
treasure vault is an excellent land that
adds to our artifact count as well as
being able to suddenly produce a bunch
of artifacts swing in with your con
structs and then suddenly make a bunch
of
treasures ö a lord High artificer easily
slots into the deck I don't have to
explain why he's so powerful anointed
procession can double up all of our
token generators while AC chroma's
Memorial can give all of your creatures
some ridiculous
abilities gin G taxis progress Tyrant is
an excellent way to double up your
artifacts while protecting your own and
dark steel Forge gives nearly everything
indestructible I've included all of my
upgrades in the considering section on
moxfield make sure to check it
out if you want to see a side by-side
comparison of the original precon list
and my list so you can see what has been
removed check out the comparison Link in
the description down below if you would
like to see the Mishra precon budget
upgrade video be sure to like this one
and let me know in the comments down
below thank you so much for watching
stay safe and I will will see you next
time
[Music]